thank you very much Rick thank you so
this is about digital and monopolies the
the classic story of course of the
Internet is that guys basically mostly
guys of course usually in garages are
cool and wear t-shirts or in their dorm
are cool and wear t-shirts or if you're
Jack Ma are cool and walk around and
interview English tourists in China and
they're really cool and entrepreneurial
and disruptive and they start little
business and its really cool and they
sort out some new things and suddenly
they rock it into this hugely dominant
position even though of course they're
really cool and entrepreneurial and
disruptive and then the actual dominance
that they then have does not allow other
cool people in garages or dorms or
walking around interviewing English
tourists in China aren't able to break
in to that now is that a problem for the
company is it real is it true and also
does it actually if it actually it's a
function of the way the internet
operates where you don't need to you
know build railways or have huge amounts
of capital intensive kit to be a
credibly successful business if your
idea is a brilliant one then growth is
very straight forward or can be I am
joined by an astonishingly brainy panel
from the right is Adam Cohen who is also
or formerly so of course I love you Adam
a journalist he is Google's head of
economic policy in Europe he was the
economics correspondent for Dow Jones to
his left is bindi Korea now she is known
as the UK queen of startups formerly at
Microsoft though interestingly we'll
talk about that hopefully a little bit
later she is vice president of silly
Silicon Valley Bank in London in the
middle ish is Andrew keen I've been
reading your book Andrew the internet is
not the answer on holidays and it's a
fantastic polemic about the way the
internet has developed and how the
contrast is between this rather we're
all guys in t-shirts just doing our own
but has actually become a force for a
lot of bad as well as a lot of good
Andrew you've been described as the
Christopher Hitchins of the internet I
saw or that means although you did say
that you have also been described as the
Antichrist of the internet so at least
you're improving slightly to Christopher
Hitchens and next maybe you'll be the
sort of David Cameron of the internet
and you can slowly move into becoming
the Pope of the Internet and then
everyone all will love you and then
Frank Pasquale a professor of law at the
University of Maryland and author of the
book black box society the secret
algorithms that control money
information clearly a professor of law
because you're wearing a tie so that's
good I took mine off I'm the BBC's
business editor I'm quite dull but I
thought as I'm now in you know trendy
East London I'm gonna take my tie off
but I have got it with me just in case
is anyone here from the BBC so let's
let's kick off let's kick off with the
actual question now monopolies got a bit
of a debate about monopolies before we
came on and Adam as a economics brain
box
you said monopoly and dominance slightly
interchangeable I think we're talking
more about dominance than monopolies but
I don't give you your give me your
opening force on this notion about is
dominance a dirty word and are there
threats from the way the internet and
businesses on the internet have
developed to the way people use the
internet and therefore society itself so
I think the definitions don't really
matter that much I think they're there
historically was this idea that really
big very successful very rich companies
could do great things for us Theodore
Vail who was the chief executive ATT 100
odd years ago said you know give me this
power and I will do great things for
your for your network I think that we've
you know have that a lot of experience
across lots of industries that this is
actually not good that competition is
necessary to promote diversity and
choice and innovation and quality those
things that we care about if we look at
you know any kind of historical legal
monopoly case
you know the actual regulation of these
issues it's tremendously important now
if we look at the internet what we see
over the past you know 15 20 years even
the past five years there's a tremendous
pace of change tremendous changes in the
way that people are finding and
accessing information in the way that
they're using their you know the
Internet itself you know more than 50
percent of access to the Internet today
in Western Europe and the United States
is happening on mobile devices so I
think we have to look very closely for
these types of changes this rapid
evolution to ensure that things are
actually functioning well so now what do
you think if we turn a bindi to this
question about this dominance issue from
where you sit now supporting and funding
startups do you see there being a
dominance problem well I think I can
come at it from the perspective of
having worked in Europe
most of my career but mainly for three
American companies and I don't see what
the problem is in the sense that you
execute and you deliver and you've got
people that like and buy and use your
product set so is it dominance or is it
a case of you know incredible execution
and then the other comment I'd make and
I've been chatting to a few friends that
have worked in policy and you know the
various big tech corporates and what is
the tension between innovation and
dominance and can the to co-exist you
know or regulation from this side of the
pond so do you believe that that any
dominance that is evidenced is simply
because that business is very good at
what it does they're very good at what
they do and more importantly they're
very good I'm a very basic business
person in the sense that they're very
good because people are adopting it and
in today's time and age and era of
social media you know it's about that
kind of adoption so execution for me so
Andrew no problem no problem at all
they're just very good at what they do
Google is a rather nice company
we should sort of write a different book
saying how the internet is the answer
the issue is not whether they are good
at what they do
no one's arguing they're not good at
what they do AT&T was good at what they
do so what that's not the issue that's
not what we're here to talk about we're
here to talk about whether or not the
digital economy lends itself to new more
excessive kinds of monopolies and those
monopolies I think are extremely
problematic when it comes to both
competition and innovation and as at
least I argue in my book in the internet
is not the answer the Internet
ironically even though it's decentered
and distributed and all these other cue
words you hear at events like this it
actually lends itself even more to a
winner-take-all economy so companies
like Google and Facebook and Amazon are
in many ways monopolies we don't have in
in almost any space in the digital
economy we don't even have two companies
that they're winner-take-all economies
and this is bad for entrepreneurs it's
bad for innovators and it's bad broadly
now whether it should be banned well how
you deal with it in a regulatory issue
is another is another matter it's not
what I'm not arguing that the people
there aren't competent the fact is
they're too competent but that's a
problem for all of us addict is be
rather it's less good at your job well
you know when you say monopolies it sort
of undermines the whole case right the
idea of monopolies is that you have one
and that there is no competitor to this
one yeah we cannot be there in in
southern Europe I mean you have 90
percent of the search market what's your
control of the search market in the UK
you're deciding that our only
competitors are actually Microsoft and
Yahoo and that all these other services
the diversity that I've described
earlier doesn't somehow exert these
competitive forces on Google's business
and those competitive forces are doing
all the things that we want to see in a
well-functioning marketplace they're
forcing us to continue to innovate to
convey to new bride new products and
continue to keep prices low those are
the classical measures that we have do
you think on Andrews main point which is
that the digital economy this is not
about Google you're not here is the kind
of spokesperson for big companies on the
internet but the digital economy lends
itself to natural let's call it
dominance of one big player in each
sector I think it lends itself to rapid
disruption and you look at you looking
at Yahoo 15 years ago Yahoo was
described as having solved search Yahoo
was the dominant player in search
they're the most data they were the most
used they were the most talked about
company in the internet in a small
little company which is today a very big
and successful company will admit it
toppled them almost overnight and the
same processes happened to to myspace
with Facebook and even the existence of
services like Facebook hasn't prevented
Twitter from emerging and snapchat and
the next great things are coming down
you know coming down the road there is
no you know stopping that process and
what about that so actually what you get
yes you may have some dominance for a
period but given that people can change
the services they use in the digital
economy very very easily that that
dominance can be can crumble in the face
of better competition I think that this
idea we should keep on hearing about
right well the competition is only one
click away doesn't work I think it's a
really interesting new book by a
Stanford professor could near Al who
talks about the book is called hooked
and he talks about the way in which we
become addicted to interface and I had
the experience myself with Google I'm a
Google user and then my my browser
shifted over to Yahoo and I was so
uncomfortable I immediately shifted over
to Chrome because I was much more
comfortable with that interface I think
what we're seeing is more and more
people flocking to single platforms I
mean you're right the first there isn't
such a thing as a first mover advantage
so you're right
Friendster didn't win Yahoo didn't win
but no one's gonna overtake Google in
search no one's gonna overtake Facebook
in social you just explained the case of
how easy it was to switch from one
service to the next which enable now I
shouldn't you know I said that your
browser for me always a problem
oh I said that in physically it seems
easy argument of people like you is or
anyone could just switch browsers but
the reality given the the habitual
nature of interface is it makes it much
much harder how do we gonna come back I
mean I think Ender's kind of answered
The Prodigy answered his own problem
right Whitney switched his preferences
Google its Chrome and when the next
better thing comes along you're gonna
switch again great and at zero cost with
zero friction right what's your feeling
about this issue of dominance and is it
a danger and why does it develop it's
not just a story about users it's also a
story about advertisers and about the
third parties that are affected and I
want to give two examples about making
this case more concretely from real
legal disputes one is that we have
emails on earth now in Silicon Valley
between top level people at Google and
Apple that were essentially a wage
fixing cartel with respect to the
workers there there was anti poaching
greens and that case has gone forward I
think it's been settled for hundreds of
billions of dollars I mean this is a
very important case that shows
anti-competitive impulses with respect
to workers at the very core of these
firms if we turn from that US case to
the EU statement of objections with
respect to price comparison sites we can
see that between 2007 and 2014 the
traffic to the leading price comparison
sites went down markedly over 75 percent
while the traffic to Google's competitor
site that Google Shopping went up at
least 200 percent that is a chilling
message to entrepreneurs that as long as
you do not affect the core business of
Google maybe you'll you know rise or
fall in search results but here's one
object lesson that if you threaten
certain core properties you should watch
out because you could be illuminated
like that and my final point would be
that so many entities especially in the
media but beyond there rely incredibly
on Google as the source of their traffic
and I think just as we saw the railroads
were incredibly important monopolies or
tell
or utilities and other in previous eras
as enlightened regulators we have to
take on the responsibility of seeing
these new digital infrastructures as the
new utilities the new railroads the new
telephones and Frank where does that
dominance come from do you agree with
Andrew that there is something in the
way the digital economy operates that
naturally leads towards these very
dominant companies developing positions
business models it was even admitted by
Peter Norvig one of the chief data
scientists at Google who said once we
don't have the best algorithms we just
have more data than everybody else
okay and the key to that idea there is
that when you look let's say that we
were to search today for a Thai
restaurant near shortage Town Hall okay
there are certain search engines that
get maybe a hundred searches like that a
week there are others that maybe get two
or three over time if you think about
this compounding this advantage
compounding over time the search engines
that get the most results are going to
have the most data about refining future
results so this is a rich get richer
dynamic that is going to further
entrench the big players the Amazons the
apples the Facebook's the Twitter's etc
in each of their respective fields of
dominance do you not agree with Adams
point though that if we look five 10
years ago and look at what were the
dominant businesses then they are very
different from the dominant businesses
now and that competitors can come in and
undermine what seems like impregnable
dominance in the digital world very
easily an example of say some search
engine displacing Google in a national
context in the past five or six years I
think that when Google took over from
Yahoo there was far less computing
equipment at stake I mean now there's
hundreds of billions of dollars of
servers that say a start-up would have
to have there was farming far less data
there now there's far more of a data
advantage and the big players I mean
even look at quai row which was this
European Union attempts is like
developed their own search engine a
rival for the Americans from about I
don't know five or six years ago they
had 450 million dollars to donate that
were so dedicated to that and it was
clearly going to fail they knew from the
outset we have Microsoft possibly losing
two million dollars a year on
they're failing so I think that the that
question answers itself but this is a
self-reinforcing dominance that we
really have to treat as a new form of
utility not as a competitive field now
Bindu you work a lot with startups and
first and second stage funding rounds I
mean do you does the operation of
dominant players in the sectors where
these new businesses are trying to grow
negatively affect the chances of the
businesses your funding I can only talk
from a personal perspective of the
companies that I've worked with and I
would actually boil it down to the
traits and the characteristics of the
entrepreneurs they don't see that as a
barrier at all and they will just
continue to go and grow and build and
try to work the best kind of company or
product that they're building but that's
purely from my own perspective of the
folks I've worked they met they may not
see it as a they may not see it as a
problem and that's a good thing some
would argue but do you but is it a
problem I don't believe so now right so
they don't so because the argument is
sometimes that the dominant companies
will brought buy up new technologies
either to to take advantage themselves
of that or to simply close them down and
meld them into their own businesses is
that a reasonable criticism it's a
reasonable observation however what I'd
say is I know of cases of really great
companies here in Europe where some of
the dominant players have offered to buy
them up and the entrepreneurs and the
founders have said no we actually
believe we can build a bigger stronger
higher valuation of a business so I
think it really depends on the founder
and those that do and have chosen to
sell out again the ones that I know that
I've sold to a Google or a Microsoft for
example they've done it because they
felt there was the right kind of
partnership for them and they could grow
you know internally and they would get
the resources they needed to grow their
product set so I think it really depends
on the founder from from my own
experience I know how do you respond to
this notion that actually yes five ten
years ago it was possible to be the
disruptor and to break down old
monopolies but now your position
particularly let's say Google but for
others as well is an Amazon maybe and
others is so dominant that it is going
to be
possible to go through that cycle again
I think if you look at these firms
they're each other's biggest competitors
and there are new entrants that are
coming along and trying to disrupt them
as well you know it's it's interesting
if you look at Google's business there's
a huge chunk of our business where we
don't make any money there no
advertisements against queries like how
far is shortage from central London but
if you look at shopping if you look at
travel if you look at searches for
restaurants there's an enormous
ecosystem in each of these areas where
there are extremely strong competitors
that are doing those things to our
business exerting those competitive
pressures forcing us to innovate forcing
us to keep prices low that's the crucial
stuff that happens in competition and we
have to acknowledge that it exists now
the Franks point that Google is somehow
this pipe connecting upstream providers
of goods and services to end-users that
this doesn't match the reality that we
have today right I mean I newspapers
made this argument in 2008 in 2009
today newspapers get more clips from
Facebook and Twitter than they do from
Google I'm gonna come to the audience
for questions in one second I want to
ask though Frank what should we be doing
about if it is a problem or you say
there's a problem what should we be
doing about it and who should be doing
it is it governments is it regulators is
it us as consumers I think that media
literacy is key getting people to try
new things and to try new approaches to
searches and to be aware that say there
can be favoring of Facebook's own
interests or Google's own interests or
Amazon's interesting there when you look
for things on them but I think
fundamentally you've got to have
regulators involved to make sure that
say when you're searching on Google for
something you're not immediately routed
to Google owned or Google affiliated
properties and the very top of your
searches that there's some room in that
prime real estate for exactly the
startups that we care about for them to
innovate for them to get some sort of
traction can I add
it's not just a question of using the
example of Google it's not just a
question of Google in surge it's the way
in which companies like Google use their
dominance in one vertical to build
businesses in other verticals and that's
what the regulator's in Europe I think
are rightly looking at uncompetitive
behavior and the last panel which was
excellent was on artificial intelligence
that's the next big thing and Google are
massively investing understandably like
Facebook like everybody else in it we
have a huge arms race when it comes to
artificial intelligence in Silicon
Valley so if they are so dominant in
search and then they use that search
domination to strengthen new businesses
that's extremely problematic and needs
to be looked at by regulators on things
like AI Adam he's describing a process
where we're entering into an incredibly
competitive field you know you talk
about AI Facebook Google lots of other
firms are interested in this these are
all competitive environments we have to
acknowledge competition where we see it
and whether or not a firm invests its
profit or not in it but they're not in
search there's there absolutely are if
you look at searches on Amazon is the
big player in shopping Expedia and kayak
and others are the big players in travel
they enter exerting competitive pressure
on us the idea that somehow competition
can only come from firms that do 100% of
what you do is not correct it's not the
standard that regulators use and it's
misleading but search is not just
another category it is the brain of the
Internet okay let's have some questions
lay down here and a gentleman there are
there some mics I think come back it's
not much fat miss lady here and a
gentleman there is there just the one
mic okay there's a gentleman over there
madam yes hi thank you for the
discussion my name is Sofia and I work
at a media tech company called blasting
news it's a very new company so we've
been going to VC's and one of the
questions that we are asked all the time
is who's going to buy you Facebook or
Google and essentially well we
here to take office so I wonder what you
think about that is there something
inherently wrong when we're essentially
being asked this question which implies
that build your company in order for it
to be bought by Facebook or Google I
want to do the VCS are that you're
talking to because ultimately is the VCS
that I've worked with over the years are
like what's your exit strategy and yes
right now the trend is that there's a
lot of acquisitions happening from these
big corporates but you know a long time
ago you know it was around market and
IPOs and flirtations so I think it
really depends in the end the motivation
of the VC is to make a return and
whether a Google or a Facebook by you or
whether it is an IPO either way the
motivation is about making their return
so how do you make them their money back
in multiples Frank very briefly that's
the so it's really exactly how so can I
ask a question for a slightly different
angle my name's Rupert gray I'm a
natural prophecy lawyer this is not much
about monopolies but about the power of
the major companies we've been talking
about couple of years ago Arkansas in
stage a question yeah yeah it's coming
up passed a law banning gay marriage as
a result of which Google Facebook and
other major major companies pulled out
of Arkansas stopped doing business there
and so we've got a situation in which
moral issues being dictated to or being
dictated by corporate interests in spite
of the fact that the democratic process
has made that decision that maybe one we
disagree with but that's not the point
so sudden you've got these companies be
more powerful of governments they're no
more partner with each other how are we
going to address that I likes their
energies use on this a you to
politically or to have a firm firms move
around for a range of reasons and
they're entitled to you know just as
citizens exert their rights so can so
can companies you know the idea that a
company needs to stay put when the law
changes and you know sometimes legal
change
our favorable sometimes they aren't
that's I don't think that that's a
principle that's established anywhere
where we have free markets or free
people talk about that it's not true
that having longer data sets makes you
better at search all machine learning
involves windowing so having a longer
data set isn't making Google better at
search it seems likely to me that what's
making Google successful and other firms
successful the same things that are
driving us to smaller range of firms in
publishing and everywhere else which is
a series of policies that are extremely
favorable to invest excuse me to
investors at the expense of States
workers and other people in their supply
chain and why should we assume that the
convergence and digital is suah generis
when we're having convergence and energy
and convergence and shipping and
convergence in all these other areas
where these returns at scale thanks to
things like the double Irish and so on
are available to them Google's not
succeeding in other verticals look at G+
right it's a I've got tumbleweeds I can
sell you from G+ Google's succeeding at
double Irish thanks
you'll succeeding because you you'll
this is this is the key question of
market power this is you know can you
use your your position in general search
to leverage your way into shopping or to
travel and the fact is is it you know we
do have a shopping property you know
where we are in shopping here and you
know where Amazon eBay and a range of
price comparison services they're all
growing just fine happens of an eBay
aren't price and price and so they are a
friend of price comparison services they
do perform that function they there's a
range of products from across to the
marketplace well you know there's an
argument by who you can pay yourself to
yeah yeah yeah okay now I see Ronan
dummies down here mister mobile guru
it could be gay the microphone down here
that'd be fabulous and then there's a
lady a woman at the back they're very
brilliant brilliant rollin just
introduce yourself ran and done I'm CEO
of telephonic in the UK or o2 and an
observation and then a question is if
we're going to have effective
competition which is the alternative to
monopoly we'd need to find a way that
the same service provided by two
different parties needs to be treated in
the market in the same way I offer
communication services and I'm regulated
on the provision of that others are for
communication services and they aren't
so I would say that if we want to have
more competition and protect against
monopolies let's have a single level
playing field for the provision of
services and let the customer decide
it's asymmetric at the moment in that
Google's in lots and lots of areas but
it's not regulated where you feel you
are over you know that's a great point I
mean look at look at obviously is coming
from the position of his company is
regulated but then what that comes along
gets bought by Facebook for whatever it
is some obscene amount of money twenty
billion dollars and it doesn't work
under the same regulations I think that
question from out there was good the
reality is is that the Internet economy
is no different from any other and the
problem with a lot of our leading
Internet companies is that they think
they're different this is going to be
our debate at the end and these
companies should be treated in the same
way under the same laws by the
regulators Alec don't make 1d groan it
makes a very good point you know text
messaging and voice calls are competing
with services like Skype they're
competing with services like whatsapp
but the interesting thing is that the
telecommunication firms across Europe
say that Google's only competitor is
Bing so we have to acknowledge
competition where it exists it's not all
like for like it's not all just the same
services exerting competitive pressures
on each other so I very much agree with
that view lady the back there and then
gentleman here hello I was an
intellectual property lawyer for many
years so I'm speaking from a legal point
of view on antitrust and monopoly it
seems to me that the problem with
monopolies is that it used to be that
you could go against if you had a
company that actually sold a product
directly against someone like a washing
machine or whatever it was you could say
they had a monopoly and the US
government would break them up in this
case because of the nature of the
digital world you're having Google what
product are they actually selling and I
think that's one of the big problems is
that we don't have a legal system that
can break up a monopoly because we don't
define it legally in a correct way and
I'm just interested in your thoughts on
that Frank don't to kick us off there's
a gentleman down here I'm afraid I'll be
the last one this guy who is the guy you
saw yes sir
yes Frank he's an interesting one but it
is one that the Federal Trade Commission
of the US has addressed repeatedly over
the past 10 years of service define
separate search advertising markets in
other markets and that actually gets to
the point about the questioner who said
that search was really a matter of
double-win doing and the rest rub in the
data all that I can say to that is that
it defies common sense to think that if
Google has ten years of email about me
and hundreds of thousands of pages of
data about me and then a competing
service has none of that information and
I type in ranges of queries that somehow
that competing service will have the
data advantage that Google has with
respect to this enormous apparatus of
surveillance those gentlemen that it has
all around me so I just sort of feel
like if you look at the way in which
general-purpose search has been defined
as a market by the FTC by the U other
areas then that is a way to get us to a
clarified to be and it comes out in
things like the data advantage that
leads to self-reinforcing with badges
and search we now visit a problem that
we regulars regulators both
geographically and globally find it very
hard to pin down digital businesses I
think that you know the same tools that
regulators have used for over a century
in addressing questions of monopolies
still apply what is the company doing a
potentially dominant company doing to
quality and innovation you know we've
seen examples where where that subsides
very rapidly when firms achieve a
position of market power and what are
they doing the prices we have very very
good tools and powerful tools that the
FTC is used and the European Commission
is used and and they basically don't
agree with what you're saying Frank
right sir last question Luc Delaney
former Facebooker and former Googler for
a full transparency and now I advise
startups on public policy and regulation
and Andrew made an interesting point
about there isn't a level playing field
perhaps or at least it's perceived but
for regulation and the way that services
are regulated around the world but that
may well be because the regulations in
Europe for example are actually more out
slowing down innovation and protecting
established businesses on a
country-by-country basis and that we
would do a lot better by liberalizing
and freeing up the telecoms companies to
be more competitive with whatsapp rather
than trying to stop whatsapp from
breaking down or challenging established
European industries so monopoly is a
dirty word used on American companies
but global success stories when it's
when we talk about Europeans and the
European digital single market plan has
just been published has been said you
know we want to celebrate and create a
European digital single market how can
we limit American platform companies
which is just madness so should we not
be liberalizing regulation rather than
trying to shut down the big successful
international place we just basically
trying to regulate against success
what's up face book so shouldn't we call
it face book and then sort of talk about
sort of having this Clash of the Titans
between the telecoms and Facebook's etc
I think when we look more deeply it's
not a question of competition it's a
question of cooperation and the closer
you look at the big content big media
big telecoms the big Internet
they are getting closer and closer
together I think often to the detriment
of startups and consumers
Andrew final thought by authorities
think historically back in the mid 90s
we had a company Microsoft that had the
same sort of power as some of these
companies today they were taken on they
were broken up and that enabled
remarkably new innovative companies like
Google and Facebook I think we we've
we've come full circle and the real
benefit for entrepreneurs in this lady
at the front I think made the point is
that we need more regulation more more
more regulatory investigation of these
new dominant companies for the benefit
of both innovation and entrepreneurs
been to Europe Microsoft I was final
thought I would disagree Microsoft was
beaten over the head with the Standard
Oil of a 99 I lived through the period
of regulation so I was there from 2005
to 2012 so internally I witnessed the
organization transform and I witnessed
how the type of language we would use
when we're in external sales situations
were frowned upon and towards 2012 it
was absolutely a soccer ball offense and
I think it's a truly different company
now so my comment would be can
regulation and innovation coexist well
II can't change Microsoft's their babies
successful out of final thought you've
got regulators breathing down your neck
in Europe yeah I'm comfortable is that I
think I think that regulation and and
government scrutiny is absolutely you
know comes hand-in-hand with success and
company should not you know buck against
that I think that you know we have to
examine the data and have rational
discussions about where competition
actually exists big is not by nature bad
and if if consumers have choice if they
continue to benefit from innovation and
they aren't stuck using products then
well Andrews at Andrews amused but he
switches very easily between these
different browsers look so he's Peter
nodding I thinks it's good to have fans
but I
let's examine the data let's have a
rational conversation I don't think we
should use rhetorical tricks to say big
is bad and therefore these companies are
bad excellent what a great panel Adam
and thank you very much - Kumar for his
excellent chairing that run reports of
Kumar please